pierre laurin bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france pour parler de
ce dossier ukrainien avec la tension qui
est au plus haut néanmoins le dialogue
se poursuit le chancelier allemand olaf
scholz qui est attendu demain à moscou
aujourd'hui il sera à à kiev qu'est ce
qu'on peut attendre de cette rencontre
eh bien on ne peut attendre rien de plus
que les précédentes
le dialogue continue effectivement et
c'est le fait positif
maintenant une fois que le contact est
établi la difficulté ne vient pas des
européens elle ne vient pas des français
elle ne vient pas des allemands elle
vient plutôt des ukrainiens et des
américains les ukrainiens ne veulent pas
entendre parler des accords de minsk du
moins dans la vision
des russes les russes ont une vision
très précise des accords de minsk parce
qu'ils ont été négociés par eux en
particulier mais également bien entendu
par la france l'allemagne et l'ukraine
simplement entre temps les ukrainiens
ont changé de gouvernement
ils ne sont pas du tout d'accord sur
certains points qui avait été acceptée
par le président paulson co lorsque les
accords ont été signés en 2015 et
aujourd'hui ils essayent de faire valoir
une vision de ces accords de minsk qui
ne correspond plus à la réalité telle
qu'elle avait été signée et donc les
ukrainiens constitue aujourd'hui la
force principale de blocage et les états
unis de l'autre côté eux essayent de
maintenir une pression permanente sur la
russie pour les raisons que l'on connaît
qui qui qui sont celles de eux
l'existence il faut qu'il y ait en
europe pour que l'otan continue
d'exister il faut qu'il y ait un ennemi
ennemi c'est la russie et les etats unis
sont dans cette optique et donc ils
envoient des signaux à kiev qui vont
parfois au delà des attentes de kiev par
exemple en ce moment sur la rhétorique
de l'invasion kiev est beaucoup plus
modérée et elle demande aux états unis
de ne pas
créer une ambiance particulièrement
catastrophistes parce que ça ne
correspond pas à la réalité telle
qu'elle est constaté sur le terrain
alors juste et donc c'est ces deux
éléments qui empêche réellement une
solution négociée et qui entrave les
négociations de maquereaux et demain de
choses justement pire l'en avant le
limier helens qui s'est entretenu hier
avec joe biden il a demandé à son
homologue américain de venir à kiev mais
washington n'a pas mentionné dans son
compte rendu cette invitation comment
est-ce qu'on peut l'interpréter
c'est parce que le président joe biden
n'est pas je pense en état d'aller à
kiev et s'il est en état d'aller à kiev
il n'est pas en état d'avoir une action
déterminée parce que bon c'est un c'est
un homme qui visiblement a des
difficultés
disons cognitive que et multiplie les
lapsus les absences c'est que ce n'est
pas forcément le bon interlocuteur pour
négocier au nom des états unis et en
plus se déplacer jusqu à kiev alors que
visiblement
on n'est pas dans une période
particulièrement propice à ce genre de
déplacement
c'est pour les américains c'est quelque
chose qui ne peuvent pas accepter alors
la russie elle de son côté s'inquiète de
la relocalisation du personnel de
l'océan en ukraine pourquoi cette
inquiétude préciser nous expliquez nous
l'eau et cec le garant de la sécurité de
la coopération en europe c'est quelque
chose est incertain l'organisme qui est
issu des négociations
d'helsinki dans les années 70 qui
avaient terminé la guerre froide une
certaine manière c'était à cette époque
que l'on avait établi les principaux
traités de désarmement de réduction des
armements d'abord de la stabilisation
puis de la réduction des déséquilibres
les traité sur les forces
conventionnelles à l'europe les
sur les missiles intermedia etc tout ça
ça découle et de des avancées qui avait
été permise par les accords d'helsinki
et et la création de l'ol c'est l'eau et
c'est aujourd'hui se situe dans une zone
qui d'après les américains risquent dans
la d'être envahi par
la russie donc le fait que le fce décide
de transférer ses bureaux c'est un très
mauvais signe parce que cela indique que
l'organisme qui est chargé de régler la
sécurité la coopération dans le sur le
continent européen
et croit à la version américaine de la
prochaine invasion de la russie alors
que les pays de l'union européenne
refuse absolument de transférer leurs
leurs ressortissants ou leur le
personnel de leur ambassade de les
réduire et c'est donc il ya là une sorte
de dichotomie entre d'un côté
les états unis et les organismes qui
sont dépendants rang 2 et de l'autre les
européens qui sont beaucoup plus modérés
beaucoup plus pondéré mais que d'une
certaine manière on ne peut pas écouter
tout simplement parce que leur action
est entravé par justement cette
folie d'une certaine manière cette folie
et de propagande qui fait qu' on ne sait
pas où l'on se situe et manière les
fonds très claire aujourd'hui les états
unis prévoyait au départ une invasion
pour le 16 février à mesure que le 16
février se rapproche et bien la date
devient de plus en plus floue on ne sait
pas on ne sait pas donc on établira que
ce sera le 15 mars et puis ensuite que
ce sera le 24 avril et ainsi de suite
donc du coup dans les prochains jours on
ne peut pas s'attendre à une désescalade
diplomatique malgré le dialogue qui se
poursuit
ce qui peut arriver parce que finalement
la france et l'allemagne
non la main que sur un point très précis
ce ne sont pas les interlocuteurs idéaux
pour les pour la russie
en ce qui concerne les garanties de
sécurité les garanties de sécurité c'est
les états unis et l'otan au delà c'est
pas possible les en revanche la france
et l'allemagne font partie du quartette
de normandie des quatre pays qui sont
censés
veiller au respect des accords de minsk
de 2015 et c'est là que la france et
l'allemagne ont un rôle à jouer parce
que ils peuvent faire pression sur kiev
pour
engager ré engager un dialogue ou plus
haut niveau et qui lui pourrait
effectivement permettre des avancées et
ce dialogue au plus haut niveau c'est la
réunion des quatre chefs d'état au
format normandie je pense que la france
et l'allemagne sont d'accord sur cela la
psy aussi et il reste à persuader
l'ukraine qui est très réticente parce
que l'ukraine se trouve dans une
position qui est très particulière si
elle accepte cela c'est à dire de
d'exclure les états unis du jeu en
revenant au quartet initial eh bien il
le soutien des etats-unis risquent
d'être un peu plus modérées un peu plus
faible ils peuvent poser des conditions
et c'est donc qu'ils sont finalement
entre entre deux chaises et c'est raide
c'est une situation très délicate en
particulier pour le président macron
qu'ils étaient persuadés en arrivant à
kiev après sa visite à delà des mers
poutine lundi dernier que kiev allait
accepter
que l'on continue de parler des accords
de minsk et que l'on trouve une solution
et il s'est heurté à une fin de
non-recevoir de zelensky qui a dit que
ce n'était pas possible dans les
conditions actuelles d'admettre la
vision russe des accords de minsk merci
beaucoup pierre laurin pour votre
éclairage ce matin je le rappelle vous
êtes journaliste et écrivain française
spécialiste de l'ua à 16 du monde post
soviétique et de la russie